- Now observe a moment
of silence...
à mille lieues du tumulte,
de la violence eviolence et de e
qui régnaient dans la même
enceinte il y a un an jourjour,s
ont observé un moment
de recueillement.
(cognements) ils ont réaffirmé
le caractère sacré du lieu
et leur attachement
à la démocratie américaine.
La vice-présidente a décrit
toute la violence de l'attaque.
"Ce n'était rien de moins,
a-t-elle dit, qu'un assaut
contre nos institutions,
nos va
Dans un discours d'une rare
dureté, et sans jamais prononcer
son nom, le président Biden
s'en est vivement prison prédéc.
"Il ne peut accepter qu'il at n
menteur, un assoiffé de pouvoir,
un homme qui fait passer
son intérêt personnel
Dans son esprit, pas le moindre
doute : Donald T
directement responsable
de ce qui s'est passéanvier 202.
"Il a fait ce qu'aucun autre
président avant lui n'avait
fait en cherchant à miner
L'heure est grave, ont ré
en coeur de nombreux démocrates.
"Jamais, a dit celui-ci,i inqui"
Donald Trump, qui devait
initialement donner la réplique
a riposté par communiqué,
accusant Joe Biden
d'instrumentaliser son nom
Les membres de sa garde
rapprochée ont echée ont echée é
le même refrain.
"On nous diffame sans
vergogne", déplore-t-elle,
du FBI. Bien  Bien  Bien  Bien t
choisi de faire profil bas
Et ceux qui se sont exprimés ont
souffl et le fro et le fro et l,
dénonçant les débordements
de l'an dernier rochant aux déms
de chercher à tirer pro
de la